i'm proud because of of the
circumstances that we were under man
this time of year
forget the opponent they name those
great faces it's about
you being able to execute your plan uh
to a level that allows you to win games
so i want to keep the focus on our guys
and what they did
mike tomlin not taking the bait to talk
about the cleveland browns it doesn't
matter at this point and look tomlin
coach of the year candidate usually we
judge the coach of the year based upon
how well his team does in comparison to
the expectations that existed before the
season started for tomlin it's very
different because it all cratered 0-3
ben roethlisberger out for the year
they're seven and two cents right and
he's holding it together with a team
that far more often than not yeah is
inferior to the team that they're
playing yeah well i i actually i mean
this is superlatives i wanted to start
there i mean i mean you can yeah i
wanted to give the i'm the man award to
mike tomlin like because i'm the man
that's what he's saying he's the man no
i mean i'm the man too but he's really
the man okay because and then one day
you played this perfectly and we did not
set this up but you know to me one of
the things and my dad and i we had this
conversation and he kind of said it so i
got to give him some credit here but no
ben roethlisberger no le'veon bell no
antonio brown it's really his team we're
seeing right now and i gotta say like
when my father said that i was like yeah
i mean you're really right and they're
playing a style of football that
shows his personality and his grittiness
and toughness and you know
his ability to lead men just to win
football games i mean mike tomlin first
off yeah i mean okay it's devlin hodges
who yeah devlin hodges he's coming in
there that was a gutsy move i mean mason
rudolph was a third round pick people
thought he might be the next guy he had
seen enough he does that but you know
managing the game the right way as far
as running the football not turning the
ball over and then relying on his
defense and what they do they're a super
bowl defense mike florio i mean they are
you know as long as their offense can
just be somewhat good they are the type
of defense that can ruin most teams game
plans with their front seven their
secondary the creativity and their
physicality so
mike tomlin yeah is on a very short list
for coach of the year and uh it's
amazing what they're doing this is a
team you do not want to play no
postseason they are going to be right we
assume that the ravens and the patriots
are going to get together in the fc
championship game let's not assume that
because the steelers are a team that
could disrupt it could you imagine a
steelers ravens game in the divisional
round right i mean you know you just
think of like
again they're going back steelers
patriots right i mean so the patriots
offense is nothing to worry about you
know gosh that defense gets a strip sack
fumble or one interception and you know
gosh oh they win a 13-10 game i don't
think that's crazy i mean of course i
mean i would pick the patriots but you
know it's it to your point they're
dangerous and they certainly are against
the ravens and their ability to to stop
the run and cause havoc up front too and
the steelers fell victim to this couple
of years ago and we assumed they would
see the patriots in the afc championship
game if you're so focused on that
rematch and tomlin was he made a bad
mistake when he had the interview with
tony dungy a couple of years ago and
presumed he was going to see the
patriots again you can't look past those
divisional round games because there are
teams in the afc like the steelers like
the bills like the chiefs if they make
it that far that can that can go in the
into new england and can go into
baltimore and uh if everything lines up
just right they could disrupt that that
presumptive afc championship game all
right i am going to
award the the the
ultra short memory award to the entire
los angeles rams organization because
the whole organization station i'm
taking the whole organization everybody
because they got destroyed yeah less
than a week ago right monday night
football it was embarrassing the defense
quit by the second half they wanted to
go home they wanted to get in bed they
wanted to crawl under the covers and
they wanted to come out for their next
game and they did and they came out and
they destroyed the arizona cardinals and
look jared goff i i criticize him when
he deserves it but i'm going to praise
him when he deserves to shake off what
happened against the ravens and to come
out and play as well as he did and and i
know look the cardinals aren't a good
team but they're in the nfl
and they have given teams like the 49ers
fits this year and the ravens
so i i am impressed by what they did and
we were talking about this last night
when we do the round table when you're
you're home in bed or doing whatever you
do yeah you're watching the game yeah
but uh they they seem to shift the focus
a little bit not throwing the ball down
the field as much underneath things
trying to maybe build a little
confidence for jared goff i think i
think that's the key you got to trust it
you can't take him off the field on
third and short you can't hand it off on
third and none you got to start trusting
jared goff he's not going to develop
into your franchise quarterback if you
don't count on him in big moments
because he's going to sense that and the
team's going to sense it they got a
rally around this guy they're stuck with
him for three more years yeah and they
got to make it to the point where they
don't feel like they're stuck with him
right so it's on sean mcvay as you've
said before he's got to figure this out
he's got to reinvent himself yeah he's
got to reinvent that offense and we saw
the first step yesterday and yesterday
was the kind of game where you're like
oh man i mean it may not be enough time
left there may not be enough games
remaining for the rams but it jumped out
but if they get into it yeah like they
did yesterday
i think they're scary i mean again the
receivers are back at full strength you
know brandon cooks you know now two back
two weeks back in the fall but i do
think it jumped out to me short passes
crossers things like that early on a lot
of play action passed they more played
through the pass to get the run going as
the game went on and golf was really
good and i still think that defense is
uh extremely impressive too i'm not
gonna let the ravens game just totally
throw me out there um
i'm gonna give it to uh he knew i was
around the corner award he wanted to
impress me
i mean he just did you know please he's
my friend he just knew he was like oh
i'm in the tri-state area you know who's
here chris sims oh i i'm talking as if i
as aaron rodgers playing the team yes
that your dad starred yeah yes yeah he
did sorry but the giants uh you know i
always root for the giants but they
didn't stand the chance against oh aaron
rodgers
because these are the type of teams
aaron rodgers can just take over against
and that's what he did pretty much in
this game they didn't have much of a run
game to talk about it was snowing and
sleeting at some points but as we were
watching the game and i was having going
oh you know i always have fun with
rogers when he makes great throws and
does things like that but you know just
the elements do not phase him uh his
ability to throw perfect spirals and
lasers right through the wind or the
snow or whatever it may be i mean
there's a deep post off his back foot
early in the game okay that gets them
going and you could see it the the snow
and rain coming down but it was a
classic rogers performance him dancing
around you know he was careful with the
ball at times it made a few throws that
all of us were just like what are you
kidding me that he's still making that
throw uh and yeah he got them back on
track as you talked about with the rams
you know they took a butt whooping last
week against the 49ers you know i think
the green bay packers are still really
good i don't know how good they are i
don't know if they're one and done or
two and done in the playoffs but uh
nonetheless rogers was really impressive
yesterday well look they're gonna be
guaranteed a home game if they win the
division whether they get a buy or not
and i think tonight's game between the
vikings and the seahawks goes a long way
toward determining that because the
packers have
an easier run down the stretch they
should be able to win three of their
final four even if they lose at
minnesota week 16 i i don't think that
keeps them from winning the division
yeah but but the viking if the vikings
are on the table then the vikings win
the division right but that's a lot to
expect when they've got the seahawks
tonight uh man they got the lions they
got the chargers
packers bears you know if the vikings
win tonight they could run the table
yeah i think i think i think a lot
hinges on tonight you know he thought he
knew i was around the corner right
that's why he did that right sure that's
exactly why he did it yeah if if if the
game had been played in anywhere but new
jersey they would have lost yeah
probably all right uh my next one is the
the bruce allen could get fired bump
award because look at what it did for
the washington football organization to
know that and for the first time ever
bruce allen's tenure is in question
there were multiple reports over the
weekend of that effect and they just go
out and they win their first game and
and look i'm being a little bit
facetious here maybe but i give a ton of
credit to the teams that had nothing to
play for this weekend going against
teams that are in the hunt
and winning those games remember that
theory last week that i was trying to oh
yeah oh yeah thanksgiving week and extra
distractions and who really cares give
me more turkey and
it's all and you agreed with me well you
know there's there's definitely some
truth to it well there wasn't some truth
to it for washington right or miami yeah
uh and and those were the two games i
was really looking at now the giants
there was truth to it there so two out
of three there wasn't but uh for the for
the washington franchise to go in and
beat a panthers team that was still very
much alive and i think some big changes
are coming in carolina because second
straight year they're collapsing down
the stretch that's not a good look when
you have a new owner who did not buy the
team because he he felt like it was his
lifetime lifelong ambition to employ ron
rivera and marty hearn yeah i think
change is coming and yesterday's game is
the kind of thing that that i think is
going to speak to that but i got to give
washington credit for finding a way to
get it done on the road against a
quality team with a christian mccaffrey
and and a franchise that that is tough
to beat at home just just a great great
win for a team that has now won two in a
row yeah right yeah here we go bill
callahan he's just running the ball
smashing people that way their defense
has always been pretty good it's just
their offense has been the issue that's
led to the defense kind of just
collapsing at certain points but you
know it is impressive you know you're
totally right and to your thanksgiving
theory and all that too you know this is
the other side of it we didn't take into
account you know and and your theory's
not wrong but the other side of it is
there is something to that team that's
playing loose and has nothing to play
for either where they can just go out
let it fly there's no extra thoughts or
overthinking the situation the coaches
can call plays that oh they know that
their jobs aren't going to be on the
line for you know hey we're two and
eight it doesn't matter what i call here
if i uh you know do something a little
daring we got one more let me put a cap
on this christian mccaffrey had 44 yards
rushing
darius guys 10 carries 129 two
touchdowns yeah game and adrian peterson
added 99. no
total domination let's jam in one more
one more i'm not ready for not ready for
prime time or i you know what do i want
to say i want to say a year away the
year away award it's official and that's
the oakland raiders okay sorry if you
guys started typing the wrong one in the
back there the year away award for the
oakland raiders is it really a year yeah
i think it's a year i do i mean look at
the leaps and bounds they made just in
this past year and i think you know you
know the one thing i think we're seeing
here down the stretch and john gruden's
done a great job with this football team
it's just if the game doesn't get
managed and go exactly how it has to
they're not good enough to overcome it
yet they're young right they got a lot
of young players throughout the
offensive defensive side of the ball and
they just don't have enough big time
difference makers yet that's really the
biggest issue they have so you know they
have to almost play the perfect game
which we saw them do a few times this
year against teams like the bears uh and
you know the minnesota vik not the
minnesota vikings game was it that the
colts game sorry you know where they
really played the right way to suit
their team but as you saw yesterday when
you got a guy like mahomes and then
derek carr throws an interception early
in the game they're not the type of team
that's going to be able to come back
they're not and that was an issue for
them they were outclassed by that chiefs
team all together yesterday and you know
the point i made yesterday on twitter
and i don't say this jokingly derek carr
may never be living in that house that
he's building well hey if he's on the
team still should sell that house and
not live next to him if he's still a
raider don't go next door don't live
next we're gonna take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports